hey this is presh talwalkar
find the value of the following series
1 over 2 factorial plus 2 over 3
factorial plus 3 over 4 factorial and so
on
this problem is adapted from a math
competition in france
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i will present three different ways to
solve the problem
let's get started using mathematical
induction
to find the value of this series we'll
take a look at the partial sum up to n
terms
let's get started by evaluating some
examples
s1 is equal to 1 over 2 factorial and
that's equal to one-half
s2 is equal to s1 plus the next term 2
over 3 factorial
we then simplify this and we get s2 is
equal to 5 over 6.
we then calculate s3
it's equal to s2 plus the next term 3
over 4 factorial
we simplify this and we get s3 is equal
to 23 over 24.
we can now see a pattern in the partial
sums
s1 is equal to 1 minus 1 over 2
factorial s2 is equal to 1 minus one
over three factorial and s three is
equal to one minus one over four
factorial
so we can speculate that s n is equal to
one minus one over n plus one factorial
we'll use mathematical induction to
prove this
we've already tested the base cases of n
is equal to 1 2 and 3.
now supposing that s n is true for some
value n is equal to k
we want to show that if s k is true then
s k plus 1 is true
so let's do that step
so we can write s k plus 1
that'll be equal to s k plus the next
term which will be k plus 1 over k plus
2 factorial
by the induction hypothesis we know the
formula for sk
it is equal to 1 minus one over k plus
one factorial
now we'll do a trick
this term will multiply by k plus two
over k plus two
we'll do this because then the
denominator will be equal to k plus 2
factorial
so sk plus 1 is equal to 1
minus k plus 2 over k plus 2 factorial
plus k plus 1 over k plus 2 factorial
we can then sum the numerators of the
last two terms
and this will be equal to one minus one
over k plus two factorial
this is exactly what we wanted to prove
so we've shown that the induction
formula is true
so this formula is in fact the partial
sum up to n terms
from here we want the value of the
infinite series which will be equal to
the limit as n goes to infinity of s n
and we look at this term as n goes to
infinity this term will go to zero
therefore the limit as n goes to
infinity of s n is exactly equal to one
thus the value of the infinite series is
equal to 1.
this is the first way we can solve the
problem
now let's use a telescoping sum
as before we look at the partial sum up
to n terms now we'll do a trick
what is k divided by k plus 1 factorial
equal to
in the numerator we'll add and subtract
1.
then we will split this into two
different fractions
one fraction will be k plus one divided
by k plus one factorial and then we
subtract one divided by k plus one
factorial
the first fraction we can simplify
the k plus 1 factors will cancel
so the numerator becomes 1 and the
denominator becomes k factorial
we then subtract 1 over k plus 1
factorial
so we'll use this
formula to simplify our partial sum
sn the first term is equal to one over
two factorial
using this formula this will be equal to
one over one factorial minus one over
two factorial
we then apply this formula to the next
term
this will be equal to one over two
factorial minus one over three factorial
we continue to apply this formula to
every single term in this partial sum
now we notice some interesting
cancellations
this pair of terms will cancel out
because negative 1 over 2 factorial plus
1 over 2 factorial is exactly equal to
0.
then the following pair of terms will
cancel out and this will happen for
every single pair of terms until we get
to one before the final term and that
will also cancel out
so this pattern is reminiscent of a
telescope that retracts upon itself
for this reason this type of sum is
known as the telescoping sum
so only the very beginning and the very
end survive
so only the first term and the very last
term survive so we once again get the
same formula for the partial sum to get
the value of the infinite series we take
the limit as n goes to infinity
again this term will go to zero as n
goes to infinity so the value of the
infinite series is equal to one
and that's the answer
so now let's go to a third way to solve
this problem
we will use a power series
so we want to evaluate this infinite
series
a general term of this will be k minus 1
divided by k factorial
now this is very similar to the power
series for e to the power of x
so we want to modify this power series
because we need instead of k over k
factorial we need k minus 1 over k
factorial
so we'll divide both sides by x so we
get e to the power of x divided by x
is equal to 1 over x plus one over one
factorial plus x over two factorial and
so on
from here we'll do a clever trick
we'll differentiate both sides with
respect to x
the left-hand side will use the quotient
rule
so we get x times e to the power of x
minus e to the power of x all over x
squared and on the right hand side we'll
differentiate term by term
we get negative one over x squared plus
one over two factorial plus 2x over 3
factorial and so on
now we will evaluate this at the value
x is equal to 1.
we'll do that because we'll get exactly
s and i'll show you in a second so we
substitute x is equal to 1 on the
left-hand side we get 1 times e to the
power of 1 minus e to the 1 all over 1
squared
then we substitute x is equal to 1 on
the right-hand side
so let's simplify the left hand side
the left-hand side will become e to the
power of 1 minus e to the power of 1 all
over 1. e to the power of 1 minus e to
the power of 1 is equal to zero so the
left hand side becomes zero
on the right hand side we'll simplify
the first term is negative one over one
then we get plus one over two factorial
plus two over three factorial plus three
over four factorial and so on
and now we have an interesting thing
the first term is negative one but then
the rest of the terms are exactly the
sum s
so from here on out these terms are
exactly equal to s so we can substitute
in then we add one to both sides and we
get that s is equal to one and once
again we figure out the value of this
infinite series but this time we use the
method of a power series
a very interesting way to solve this
problem
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you